hello I'm in the style quick I remember
I can't escape it can i I have to go
through with it don't I alright here we
go
the Star Wars Holiday Special
the rumors were true people in 1978 an
actual Christmas special was released
under the Star Wars name and it's not
like they just got some of the
supporting actors being at nope they got
the whole frigging cast Harrison Ford
Carrie Fisher James Earl Jones the ones
and not only that it has guest stars
like Art Carney Harvey Korman and Bea
Arthur because like most people when you
think Star Wars you fucking think Bea
Arthur this special has never read into
this day George Lucas has apparently
gone out of his way to make sure that
nobody sees it
so just to recap this is the guy who
said this is OK and this is OK which
means this is the project that he was
personally ashamed of I'm gonna go over
that again ok ok
personally ashamed of there are not
enough toilets in the world to contain
the amount of shit spewing fear that I
am going through right now but the
spirit of Christmas I feel I owe it to
you to give the audience a gift to
review this heinous special begin so we
see Han Solo and Chewbacca fighting all
the stock footage from the person would
be as they tried to make playful banter
at this spirit you'll be celebrating
life today before you know it like what
you'll be celebrating life today before
you know any flight day what the hell is
life day yes perhaps I should have
rephrase this title a bit it's not
really a Christmas special as much as it
is a holiday special Christmas isn't
even mentioned instead we get a wookie
holiday known as life day a holiday
probably invented by Jawa advertisers to
make more money we then cut to a
beautiful matte painting where dubaku's
family lives
why who's thank you little hunk of
armpit hair I'm guessing it's Chewbacca
son but it's sort of hard to tell
considering that they never speak
English oh my god we're gonna have to
listen to this throughout the entire
special aren't we
if you thought you bakas work out
annoying at times try a fucking choir of
it
well I do believe that five minutes in
seriously it's like watching a walking
reality show where's the lasers where
are the starships is the hairball
equivalent to Norman Rockwell really the
only thing we're gonna get
what do you think the sprint for this
look like do you think it actually
explained any more about what's going on
believe it or not I actually have a copy
of the screenplay right here let's see
what it says okay what's this all right
you're halfway there special you're in
fact doing something but how about
something that actually makes sense
whoa who's doing the 69 that's out there
I have no idea what's going on it's like
watching the Star Wars prequels
so if you're following the story okay
insurance me I know you are you learn
that they have to contact Luke Skywalker
to find out what's keeping Chewbacca so
long are we there yet is that it whoa
when to Skywalker turned into a Ken doll
I mean look at him it looks like a store
mannequin that's the 12 year old tomboy
look just at the time left here on
schedule if he's not there now they're
way overdue well that just perms my hair
don't look so worried
no Chu he's not gonna want to come home
to a house with long faces is he come on
ma let's see a little smile
come on that's better okay we'll keep
smiling should be outlawed so one of the
Wookiees I guess turns on a cooking show
where we see oh my god
wonderful just adds that touch of
frequency harvey korman no design no
please go back to the cooking I don't
want to see all this sci-fi action I
want to see how the fucking dinner turns
out say that again
one life they won't soon forget you ever
notice that never actually acknowledge
what life date is I mean my guess is
it's a celebration of life but what does
that entail what's the history of it how
long is it been around it's not really
much of a holiday special if you don't
explain the goddamn holiday oh good
we're back to the Wookiees that was
about 120 seconds of Harrison Ford you
just saw there you know when you hide
the cast of Star Wars we expect to see
the cast of Star Wars not these walking
dog anuses all day
yeah the dialogue is still riveting what
if it is an Art Carney and yes I
double-checked I know it's really hit
I guess he's helping the rebels and
their battle against the Empire and
Chewy's family are friends of the
resistance why all the long hairy faith
I made it through the Imperial patrol
tonight what you talking about Connie
that was a lady the whole time happy
life they'll insert this proton pack I
thought you might like this one of those
that that's a whale it kind of hard to
explain it's a yeah
Wow world of warcraft so I think grandpa
wookie enters the matrix or something as
we see him enter some kind of machine
where he watches wookie spur yeah that
sounds about right
as you create me oh yes
we are excited hardly max just for that
we can have a good time
if this is a traditional life day
pastime
I am your fan I am your experience I
have experienced me this is wrong this
is a holocaust of wrong I am your
patient this look no I mean I know you
like it shave this is what would you
look like without all my fern why can't
we see proposed hands this is our moment
together in time what is up with this
special first of all Star Wars I can't
oh right away how we can connect it to a
holiday special second our queue is just
the most attractive creatures in the
universe I mean you got jammed up what
are you lay on that slave outfit and now
you got a Wookiee jerking off to this
chick how many either species love nests
are there oh good because this special
wasn't getting up already would you do
me a favor and send either to back or
Han Solo to the screen please she says
but she would like to grant your request
but is quite unable to do so you mean I
haven't arrived yet she says there has
been no contact you know I never figured
out how the stupid translations of this
world war how come the wookie can
understand the English that Leia is
speaking but can't manage to speak it
herself
is it because their lips don't make Oh
sounds that Imperial patrol must be
giving them more trouble than we
bargained for good thing I'm the leader
of the club that's made for you and me
mala are are you alone
but all might be okay they hear a ship
landing outside and assume it must be
Chewbacca if they hear you've been
hiding Jewish epochs so the Empire drops
in because they suspect the Wookiees are
wrong do it now what key food isn't the
greatest but I'm sure that I can whip
something up in the kitchen there that
we can all eat don't my dear mama not
only oh come on you're cooking airplane
what why don't you come under carry that
hot babe isn't that a wise way of saying
merry Christmas to you
so Kearney tries to distract the
stormtroopers by playing get this a
music video
Wow they don't have holiday so I'll
bring Jesus and galaxies far far away
but they sure do have Jefferson Starship
singing a love song into a dildo
god it's like the special got bored of
itself and so I decided to change the
channel to be aged one point
if you point them all on we're going to
be here all night so after six minutes
of nothing but that song we finally get
to see some action-packed laser shooting
sci-fi adventure with our main heroes in
cartoon form da I'm the punch miss
special on the matza fight toy so take
our two with your area it's not even
good cartoon either it's like a dragon's
lair
Falcon
it's chewy but where's Hans and where
are my nostrils for that hair whatever
he's doing there must be a reason he's
on a collision course let's just learn
mortal danger from actually is it me or
is the animation done by the same
numbnuts who did those horrible zelda CD
games these are the faces of evil what
are you getting set to see if I can
locate the Falcon fight visuals writing
maybe it's close by oh no we landed in
bedrock the only thing that people
really seem to remember about this
cartoon is that Bubba met some character
who got like a ton of popularity for
some reason actually makes his first
appearance here it'll be easy to find
the ship you seek follow me friend
but who cares everyone else looks like a
McDonald's character so it's not like
he's coolness factor is going to save
anything I'm afraid that it's because
you said boba is a friend and in a
minute what does c-3po boy what's the
purpose
now you got the trust in you I see why
they call you the best bounty hunters we
got out of James Earl Jones and nothing
else
real nice yeah can't even keep the build
in the recording studio for four fucking
minutes he says our friend
why does Sol look like Richard Gere's
wrinkled up caricature
Chewbacca suspected all the love there
was something bad about Foofa how did
you know Chewie didn't smell right may
the force be with you oh please don't
come back to the plot now there must be
something else you can watch or put on
to waste our time
this instruction cassette provided by
the manufacturer
this product was packed under strict and
instruction they're actually showing us
an instruction video are you fucking
real the motor abilities was the killer
that show just canceled at this time
Harvey Korman is in like five separate
scenes but now let's get started shall
we
so if you thought this special couldn't
possibly get any more boring Harvey
Korman pretending to be a robot I guess
demonstrates how to put together a
transmitter and yes they show you every
single solitary thank you for selecting
our brand of mini transmitter if you
assemble it properly following the
instructions I am about to give you it
will provide many years of funds first
find the sealed package containing all
the tools you'll need it looks like this
why is this just try not to rip it open
because it makes a very handy storage
case for your tools until you need them
again
I was entertaining this is the first
thing you will need please be careful
not to touch yourself on the sharp edges
oh my god I'm actually getting stupider
well find the circuit breaker module
because my college education let's start
calling these components by their proper
names every one of the 10,000 terminals
on your circuit breaker module is marked
in a particular color these must be
connected to the wires with the
corresponding colors I'm stupid now we
better turn our attention to the
Assembly of the impulse to voice
translator goddamn Christmas special
because that's the one you goddamn need
so finally after that long-drawn how
horse shit is over what did they cut to
next time now for life on Catalina so
now we cut the taraweeh light because
the Wookiee life was just so fucking
engaging that we need another one too
but in hello Nina okay we'll do it your
way
hello now we'll do it my way what'll it
be wow those two guys don't really alike
actually that's be Arthur as the
bartender and the galley is here's a
shocker
Harvey Carmen I haven't seen him in the
past five minutes of torture if you're
saying what I think you're saying you
felt you meant I thought you needed to
hear then I just have one thing to say I
didn't know now actually to be Arthur's
credit she seems to be like the only one
who's actually trying in this whole damn
thing I mean she just has the role of
bartender but
I'm actually a million times more
interested in what happens in this
stupid bar that I am the rest of the
universe then I guess you didn't hear
what I said
the Empire has closed us down all right
ones on the house well that's weird
this whole intergalactic Empire is
concerned with just closing down this
bar I mean don't they have more
important things to do you have done
well lord Vader and now I sense we must
focus all of our forces to crush this
tiny Cantina on Tatooine what of the
reports the remove fleet mass fearsome
she's of no concern
soon the cantina will be crushed and Bea
Arthur will be one of us what we need be
Arthur's Island so she has to get
everyone out of the bar and if you can
believe it actually has a musical number
I guess he did you first try stopping by
actually and I hate to say this but this
song sequence actually isn't that bad
maybe because everything else is so
horrible by comparison but I actually
feel really sad that her bar is closed
she's only character I kind of liken all
this and maybe the idea of a closing bar
that can supply me alcohol during all of
this makes me kind of emotional no I'm
here friend
Your Honor in fact you know what
this hold special show been about her
yes this special would have been better
if it was focused on beam Arthur as a
singing bartender in a cantina on
Tatooine that's how long we've gotten
people that's how low we've got good
night no I'm sorry Dee I like your place
it's a nice looking place
rookies holding it stuck in a drain pipe
but both Chewbacca and Han Solo finally
come in to try and save the day Wow
that's like the most accident-prone
stormtrooper I've ever seen
I mean stripping over your own gun how
do you think he doing a real bat well
I'd love to but I can't I got to get
back to the Falcon before somebody
stumbles across it yeah they're paying
me by the minute so I can't be here for
long
a very distant rare lazy family so I
guess the Wookiees hold up some sort of
sparkling snow glows as they're suddenly
teleported to our bright heavenly light
got any booze with it seen inside a room
with oh Jesus
more screeching wookies chopped off why
are we the ones of silly robes is it a
wookie chorus of again sing Christmas
carols no no
it is indeed true that at times like
this artoo and I wish that we were more
than just mechanical beings and we're
ready alive so that we could share your
feelings with because as machines this
seems quite unbearable to us so all the
cash shows up as Princess Leia does her
best British impression for the entire
crowd this holiday is yours but we all
share with you the hope that this day
brings us closer to freedom and to
harmony into peace no matter how
different we appear we're all the same
and our struggle against the powers of
evil and darkness did evidence you start
doing Tehran's during this special this
is the promise of the Tree of Life oh
god no not a cheesy life
and now it's a special gift I'm going to
what you might clean up this horrible
holiday special Christ has to get back
on my rocket ship see the prices of
rocket ship just so gosh darn wonderful
I love you say Chrysler Pole
Santa cries he he he
go out to the command ship and await my
further Bea Arthur related orders